die nervosität spürbar kurz zuvor hatten
kanzler scholz und gesundheitsminister
lauterbach bereits eine erste
abstimmungsniederlage hinnehmen müssen
als es darum ging in welcher reihenfolge
über die einzelnen vorlagen abgestimmt
wird dann das abstimmungsergebnis zu dem
antrag den sie unterstützten impfpflicht
ab 60 mit ja haben gestimmt
mit nein haben gestimmt
378 enthaltungen 9 voraus ging eine
debatte an der sich auch der abgeordnete
lauterbach beteiligte nachdem er lange
für eine impfpflicht ab 18 gewesen war
hat er sich zuletzt in kompromiss ab 60
angeschlossen werden wir die impfpflicht
ab 60 beginnen dann verhindern wir 90
prozent der todesfälle die wir mit einer
impfpflicht verändert hätten ab 18 davor
und danach ein offener schlagabtausch
teils jenseits von fraktionsgrenzen wenn
die data variante fiel in diesem hause
zum umdenken in sachen impfpflicht
gebracht dann musste das auftreten der
milde und hobby konnte variante
konsequenterweise ebenfalls zu einem
umdenken führen wir haben die
verantwortung jetzt vorsorge für den
herbst zu tragen liebe union auch sie
stehen in der verantwortung sehen sie
sich darauf und stimmen sie für den
gesetzesentwurf der vorliegt antwort die
union verweigerte sich nicht prinzipiell
einer gemeinsamen lösung aber nicht so
wie sie es machen um offensichtlich hier
davon abzulenken dass sie in ihrer
eigenen regierung keine mehrheit haben
für das was auf dieser fraktion kommt
die union wollte ebenfalls erst 1 im
free kiste und die voraussetzung
schaffen später eine impfpflicht zu
beschließen ein antrag der fdp wandte
sich gegen jede impfpflicht
[Applaus]
nicht nur radikal
verfassungsfeindlich
sie ist eine totalitäre anmaßung eine
entwürdigung des individuums die linke
wird unentschieden wird zunächst einzige
wortbeitrag aus ihren reihen wandte sich
ebenfalls gegen eine impfpflicht die
deutschen geisterfahrer gegen den rest
der welt wo kein mensch mehr über
endlich nachdenkt und diskutiert das
kann doch nicht ihr ernst sein nach dem
gescheiterten kompromissantrag der ampel
erhielten wie erwartet die anderen
anträge ebenfalls keine mehrheit
andrea maurer in berlin die impfpflicht
ab 60 wurde also ziemlich eindeutig
abgelehnt eine blamage für die
bundesregierung und kanzler scholz der
sich klar dafür ausgesprochen hatte
ja es ist nun tatsächlich kein guter tag
für den kanzler und den
gesundheitsminister die sich ja beide
für den gesetzentwurf ausgesprochen
haben der hier heute keine mehrheit
gefunden hat von der allgemeinen
impfpflicht die der kanzler für märz
versprochen hatte angekündigt hatte ist
jetzt nicht mal der kompromiss geblieben
gescheitert ist das unter anderem an der
union die keine mehrheitsbeschafferin
sein wollte und deren eigener antrag
hier allerdings auch gescheitert ist
gescheitert ist das aber auch an der fdp
in der viele abgeordnete und führende
figuren er sich nicht für den
gesetzentwurf ausgesprochen haben das
wird spuren hinterlassen in der ampel
sie muss sich die frage gefallen lassen
wie regierungsfähig sie ist und es wird
schwierig sein das im land zu vermitteln
wie das was wovon der kanzler und der
gesundheitsminister so überzeugt waren
wie das die mehrheit des parlaments
nicht überzeugen konnte und wie es unter
die räder von taktik und geschacher hier
heute gekommen ist